police in Los Angeles say a prankster is  under arrest for allegedly making a  false call to police in Wichita Kansas  which led to the death of a father of  two it is believed the suspect Tyler  Barris called 911 an argument with a  fellow online gamer Roxana Saberi has  the story  Wichita Police released this body cam  video of an officer shooting a man after  receiving what they now think was a  false report we believe this incident is  a case of swatting which is the act of  deceiving emergency services and to  sending a police response to another  person's address the deceased man is 28  year old Andrew Finch police say a  prankster called 911 he lived in the  home and had shot his father the caller  said he was armed and holding hostages  and made threats  this is Blaine Finch's mother is stunned  by her son's death police shot and  killed him after they say he reached for  his waistband I'm not letting go until I  have justice Finch was unarmed Roxana  Saberi  CBS News